eight 71 in this year the army came into
Wessex to reading and three days later
two Danish Earl's rode farther inland
then alderman Ethel Woolf encountered
them at angle field and fought against
them there and had the victory and one
of them whose name was Sid Rock was
killed there then four days later King
Ethelred and his brother Alfred led a
great army to Redding and fought against
the army and a great slaughter was made
on both sides and alderman Ethel wolf
was killed and the Danes had possession
of the battlefield and four days later
King Ethelred and his brother Alfred
fought against the whole army at Ashdown
and the Danes were in two divisions in
the one were the heathen kings bag SEC
and half dana and then the other were
the Earl's and then King Ethelred fought
against the Kings troop and came back
SEC or slaying there and ethelred's
brother Alfred fought against the Earl's
troop and there was saying
Earl's CID rock the old and old CID Rock
the younger and o oz burn Alf Reyna and
Earl Harold and both enemy armies were
put to flight and many thousands were
killed and they continued fighting until
night and a fortnight later King
Ethelred and his brother Alfred fought
against the Army at Beijing and there
the day's had the victory
two months later King Ethelred and his
brother Alfred fought against the army
at Meriton and they were in two
divisions and they put both to flight
and
victorious far on into the day and there
was a great slaughter on both sides and
the Danes had possession of the
battlefield and Bishop Haymond was
killed there and many important men and
after this battle a great summer
army came to Redding and afterwards
after Easter
King Ethelred died and he had reigned
five years and his body is buried at
Wimborne Minster
then his brother Alfred the son of Ethel
wolf succeeded to the kingdom of the
West Saxons and a month later King
Alfred fought with a small force against
the whole army at Wilton and put it to
flight far on into the day and the Danes
had possession of the battlefield and
during that year nine general
engagements were fought against the
Danish army in the kingdom south of the
Thames
besides the expeditions which the King's
brother Alfred and single alderman and
King Staines often rode on which were
not counted and that year nine Danish
girls were killed and one King and the
West Saxons made peace with the army
that year
[Music]
you